nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour les
enfants d'haïti qui ont besoin de notre
générosité
on a huit semaines pour récolter
cinquante mille euros tu vois aucun oui
[Musique]
à partir de maintenant tu de père
christophe
c'est empêcher les gens d'aller là bas
c'est moins bien josette de dangers du
style marie si tu savais tout le mal que
l'on me fait romary faire le taux
d'enfants sont libres au père noël
c'est quoi cette bande de bouffons dit
hors de question que j'aille par baril
pour le soudan cette année tu prends ton
puisque de faire c'est qu'est ce que
vous regardez comme ça petit minou ça
doit être gribouille la vieille chatte
de la voisine
m
bon c'est pour les enfants d'haïti c'est
pas pour les enfants c'est pour
t'acheter des vêtements je sens quelque
chose de pathétique et prêtre est
reparti tout
[Musique]
l'église bien tu eu de juge à nazareth
comme le nazareth du christ lors comme
le nazareth du poisson
[Musique]